نعم الطقس
لا شك الطقس بارد جدا
ليس اليوم فقط لكن حتى منذ ما قبل الزلزال
هذه المنطقه تشهد منخفض شديد للغايه لا شك
هناك محاولات لتوفير مواد التدفئه في معظم
الخيام
في محاوله تعاطي مع هذا الطقس البارد لكن
الجميع يعلم ان هذه الخيام لا يمكن ان تحل
مشكله في هذا الطقس يمكن ان تحل مشكله
لايام معدوده او اسبوع او اسبوعين لذلك
المرحله القادمه
وبدات بالفعل في بعض الولايات لكن هنا في
نوردا لم تبدا بعد هي نقل سكان هذه الخيام
الى اماكن ايواء مؤقته في مناطق امنه
بعيدا عن مناطق الزلزال وتحديدا الى السكن
الجامعي في بعض المناطق في وسط العام دول
او شمال تركيا او حتى انقره واسطنبول حيث
توقف التعليم في الجامعات وانتقل الى
مرحله التعليم عن بعد لذلك كل سكان هذه
المخيمات سيتم اجلائهم الى مناطق امنه في
شمال ووسط ومعظم بقيه الولايات التركيه
التي لم تتضرر من الزلزال حيث سيسكنون في
سكن الطلاب للجامعات اضافه الى خطه حكوميه
تحدث عنها الرئيس التركي في وقت سابق وهي
افراغ بعض المنتجعات السياحيه في ولايه في
ولايات مرسين وايضا انطاليا
لاستيعاب اعداد كبيره من متضرري الزلزال
نعم زيدان نحن نشاهد الان على الهواء عدد
كبير جدا من هذه الخيم التي تم اقامتها في
هذه المنطقه هل هناك تقدير لعدد المنكوبين
الذين يعيشون في هذه الخيام في هذه
المنطقه تحديدا
نعم لا شك ان معظم السكان
يقيمون في هذه الخيام لكن هذا الدقيق لا
يوجد لماذا لان
الحاله يعني بعد وقوع الزلزال هناك بعض
الاشخاص ممن غادروا المدينه بشكل فردي الى
القرى المجاوره هناك اشخاص استقلوا
سياراتهم الخاصه وانتقلوا الى مناطق امنه
في شمال
تركيا
هناك اشخاص اخرون ايضا ذهبوا الى مناطق
الى مناطق اخرى لذلك الان يعني بعد نصب كل
الخيام يعني حتى الان لم يتم نصب جميع
الخيار هناك خيام اخرى ايضا تاتي
لوجود يعني في بعض الخيام مثلا يوجد
عائلتين
لذلك الوضع بحاجه الى مزيد من الخيام عند
الانتهاء من توزيع الخيام بشكل كامل هنا
سيتم احصاء دقيق لعدد الموجودين ومن ثم
البدء بنقلهم الى مناطق اخرى كما ذكرت
يعني الخطه هذه الخيم هي خيم مؤقته ايام
او اسابيع معدوده جدا قبل ان يتم نقلهم
الى مناطق ام وهناك سكن مؤقت للجميع
وتحديدا الجامعات والسكن الطلابي في بقيه
الولايات التركيه